we are live with brett howard on the
line
where police are now confirming a
drive-by shooting at a polling station
they're all in a line shot in the head
just where they stood the whole line is
dead the line is dead looks like some
voters had children with them all spared
not even her brett local pd are saying a
suspicious device may have been
discovered
could this be slaughterbots
no parts on the ground i can see i
haven't heard any or heard of any
airborne devices
i see police i see some officers
deploying camouflage masks right now
we're on the move police are interested
in an abandoned vehicle they're heavily
camouflaged now wait there's there's
another vehicle and another vehicle
across the street they seem quite
concerned about that
look out
[Music]
yet another national security crisis for
this administration
everybody was dancing and then suddenly
we look
horrible no no no killer robots marching
down the street that can't happen
these are professional munitions and
they aren't just gonna fall into the
hands of bad guys we're building really
robust procedures whole constellation of
products at the trade show this year
this is an industry energized by last
year's successes devices apparently
hunted down and killed soldiers who are
regrouping after fleeing the battlefield
of course they can't target kids in the
street they are hard-coded to target men
in the battle space surely you mean men
and women well sure
can be added to the target profile
purely a military device for confronting
military aggression nobody is endorsing
civilian applications the second such
autonomous assassination of leading
scientists big win for regional powers
as they hope to [ __ ] their neighbor's
nuclear program
the design obstacles are dropping like
dominoes we are getting more lethal more
versatile more affordable so we can
empower more customers regime change
without the billion dollar spend or the
body bags a real lift to the smallest
armies legitimate armies though well
sure but who are we to decide who they
are
all right now we're gonna cross the u.n
where we're told the
treaty has now been signed
generations before us
thought that future wars would be fought
with toxic chemicals
and infectious germs
[Music]
they thought our landscapes would be
littered with unexploded landlines and
more recently it seemed inevitable we
were on a course to mass produce a new
class of merciless autonomous weapons
which use algorithms to decide who to
kill
we knew the dangers
but we thought we had no choice
because we thought our enemies were too
inhuman to respect innocent lives
we thought
if we didn't
they worked
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but each time we feared the worst
[Applause]
we were wrong
[Music]
together our nations have ratified a new
legally binding treaty
together we prohibit weapons which
select human targets and attack without
human control
[Applause]
[Music]
humanity must prevail on the battlefield
and from today
it will
[Music]
you